[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to the tim ferriss show episode
500 i am your host
tim ferriss i'm not tim ferriss
i'm kevin rose tim thank you for having
me dude i know i was your first guest on
episode one
but i'm honored to be interviewing you
for this episode
i am so thrilled and excited
and wouldn't have it any other way so i
am
stoked to be reunited
we have some wine i have this kind of
like magnum bottle
of white wine kevin worried that i had
already polished off 7
8 of it but i had uh i'm in the jungle
with an italian there's more to that but
the
table wine is courtesy of his house and
he gave me just enough
to it looks kind of like horse urine in
a smart shot
but uh just enough to have fun without
getting sloppy
because we have a history with one you
know what's funny
i told daria i was like okay here's the
deal i'm going to pour two glasses into
my glass
and i don't care if i'm texting you do
not bring the bottle back down
like do not do it so i actually
but i i totally screwed up and i brought
the bottle and sitting next to me now
but
uh nice it was a good plan for as long
as it lasted
um dude so you know what's funny i
remember you came to me
and you said i think i want to do a
podcast and you've done podcasts before
because i had done like 300 episodes of
dignation prior to
you know you starting yours and i
remember this is horrible but it's true
i remember just being like tim don't do
a podcast it's stupid
but i was trying to talk you out of it
i feel so bad for that now because you
went you did it and obviously it's a
massive success
so uh what do i know but uh
dude you must have given me some type of
good advice
or the bad advice wasn't compelling
enough yeah and here we are
and i remember recording that first
episode we are in san francisco my first
apartment i'd rented in san francisco
and this huge wooden table
and i remember being really nervous
we had all sorts of gear we had all
sorts of fancy you know
like mixers and everything else we had
somebody helping my hands were sweaty
and i had a list of questions a printout
yeah and i remember in that first
episode number one it was
per your description tim tim talk talk
because we didn't have a name
and then i remember asking you a
question
which was if you could be a breakfast
cereal
what would you be and why and you went
oh
it's one of those interviews
and i was like never again well i asked
that question
you had to test them out though you know
not every question works so
you you were new to the game it was it
was good training all right so i saw you
take a sip so you've got your wine yeah
what are you so you're drinking the
table wine i'm drinking grocery
table wine familia cielo c-i-e-l-o
from 1908 pinot grigio and this is what
this is your fancy what's been drinking
out of my fancy yeah like 12 ounce water
glass since i don't have any wine
glasses
i am doing the 2016 napa valley reserve
uh it is uh fantastic white wine
just a little chardonnay good stuff
congrats
on being guest number 500
and congrats to a long-standing
friendship
honestly it's been yeah cheers to that
brother lots of
lots of adventures so cheers yeah cheers
really nice uh really nice to have
continued
to deepen and stay in touch over all
these years
absolutely and i i feel like that is
probably as sentimental
as it's going to get and uh you seem to
have
lots of arrows in the quiver for
questions
you gave me a lot of words via text
message and i have not reviewed anything
uh so well so this is the cool thing is
i was putting together a google doc and
i was like okay tim we'll show the
google doc i'll put some questions in
there tell me what you think and he's
like actually
i'd rather do this just sight unseen
let's let's just roll with it
um so i went out you know did a little
uh twitter post
uh you retweeted it we got a few hundred
questions there
also some of your good friends like mr
chris saka
uh who's a mutual friend of ours reached
out and sent me some
some a very colorful questions if you
will um
so i kind of i'm kind of saving those
for a little bit well actually i'm going
to start with the soccer one but some of
the more
the more juicier ones are going to be
peppered in a little bit later in the
show
um so this is fun this is a good a good
mix
of of serious and crazy and
uh yeah it's a smorgasbord of questions
if you will
a great reading of podcasting delights
i'm ready okay
so here we go i'm actually going to lead
off with a soccer question because he
sent so many good ones
he said what one thing do you eat that
you've never wanted to admit
to the four-hour body tribe
oh boy well i will say the first thing
that comes to mind because it's a recent
example
is if i've had two or more glasses of
wine and there is pizza
within 30 feet of me
it's game over it's completely game over
so i was having a bunch of
pizza and by a bunch i mean like six to
ten slices
uh just a few days ago and this is at
the tail end
of a bottle of wine and my friend
one of my friends i was with here said
what would all of your readers of the
four-hour body say
while you're prohibiting them from
eating carbs look at yourself
and so that's that's the first thing
that comes to mind if there
are any tim tams nearby tim tams are
this
yes cookie treat that i just think are
delicious they're amazing
and there's the tim tam slam which is
when you dunk it into something like
milk or any number of other things
tim tams are also dangerous territory so
those are the pizza and tin tams
when you say 30 feet away do you mean
that like your phone is 30 feet away and
you order pizza and have it delivered to
your house because that's my
that's what i do that's my downfall i'm
i'm eliminating
the phone from this uh if
there if i walk let's just say
pre-covered times
yeah had a few drinks i'm walking down a
street to get to wherever i'm going and
we pass a piece of joint or if it's
within
like excusable rationalizing distance
like oh let's just go over and take a
look at the menu right if it's a
right turn you have to go quarter mile
i'm not going to do it so i'll
try to preserve some dignity but if it's
within wandering distance
say there's a place called home slice on
south congress
in austin and it's it's dangerously
dangerously close to the main kind of
pedestrian
area so i would i would i would succumb
yeah we're in the same camp if anything
was within a couple blocks of my house
it's like game over like that's
just gonna happen all the time um all
right so next next question
uh love the show however it seems that
you're constantly searching for the next
big life hack next product that will
satisfy etc
how um that would be exhausting and
would lead to constant anxiety
my question tim have you found peace
outside of having things
or knowing things that's a damn fine
question is this from the interwebs
it is yeah
my relationship to self-improvement or
thinking about hacks and so on
has changed over time and you know the
word hack
used to not have as much baggage as it
now does
so i use that term uh effectively never
these days because it's just established
such
or taken on such a kind of a nasty
negative overtone but
i'll tell a story i think this
illustrates how i'm
reorienting quite easily and that is
spending time with an incredible
i want to say psychiatrist he's also i
want to say an ordained ministry i may
be getting some of the details wrong
here maybe it's a masters of dfinity i
don't know
named bill richards and bill richards
is well known also for being one of the
most
experienced let's call it guides
or facilitators above ground in the
psychedelic
world so he's facilitated hundreds of
sessions along with
a woman named mary cosimano who's
who's equally impressive in so many ways
and just an
incredible human being and i spent time
with bill
he he supervised years and years of
sessions both
pre-prohibition meaning pre the
uh controlled substances act and post
so he's done all sorts of trainings all
over the world
and there there were two things that
stood out from that conversation
immediately number one i asked him what
books he could recommend
for learning more about the process of
guiding the protocols they used
that he said well so you know the
problem with books and i was like
what's the problem with books and he
said too many words
again it gives you an idea of his
personality and then the second
thing he said was uh related to doing
the work
you know because i said i'm not afraid
to do the work
and he said well you know what's so
tricky about doing the work
then i and i i asked him
what it was that was so tricky and he
said well
there's a very thin line between doing
the work and just picking on yourself
so i think that you know
self-improvement and
how much it affects you positively or
negatively for me personally depends a
lot on the motivation behind it right
like are you running away from something
are you running towards something
are you finding problems with yourself
or problems in your life just because
you've been rewarded throughout your
life as a problem solver i think that's
true for me it's true for a lot of
people
you're just good at solving problems you
get really good at finding problems
or are you doing it because there's some
joy in doing it
right so for instance right now i'm
trying to pick up a couple of different
games like board games
chess there are a number of things and
i find those really fun so i'm improving
my thinking
and so on looking at a game of complete
information like chess
learning about classical games and all
this stuff legals mate i think is one
that i learned yesterday
which is just gorgeous with uh
two nights and i'm a novice but i'm
having so much fun doing it
versus let's just say
a contrast with that would be a therapy
session that i had
yesterday where we got into all this
childhood stuff
and revisited a bunch of trauma and i
came out of the session
feeling much worse than when i went into
it
and uh it occurred to me that i think
that
we can feel like we're doing a good
thing sometimes
when we're suffering
and grinding but that does not by
default
mean that we're doing something
worthwhile or improving
and so after that session i
i sort of committed to myself not to
like dredge up
all of the pain from the past in the
name of doing the work just because i
can
so i feel like i have a very good
relationship to
hacks and all that stuff now it doesn't
cause me stress and in fact it never
really has
but i think for a very long time
i looked for problems to solve because i
was good at solving problems
and not all of those problems were
worthwhile
and many of those problems were just
masochistic
if that makes any sense it does how do
you apply this though to actual products
like for example you know you do the
five bullet friday really famous
newsletter
you're finding all kinds of stuff i
imagine people are
they just send you free stuff like if
you have any kind of following that's
like very common on the internet people
want us to try and send you things to
check out
like how do you not just accumulate a
bunch of crap like
i find that every little object you own
is some
some type of subconscious like burden
you know it's just like just storing it
it's just a psychic drag it's like
imagine dragging all that [ __ ] around
behind you in like a
a net right so what do you what do you
do what do you do there because you must
see so and get so much stuff like how do
you clear that out how do you not
try out the latest project or a product
yeah number one is i really
don't encourage people to send things to
me
uh i mean you know this because for
better for worse
you've turned into my unpaid executive
assistants
people try to go through you and i'm
just like nah i'm good
i'm good for now and uh what i'll very
often do
number one i have policies so i try to
make one decision that removes a
thousand decisions
right so even in 2009
i was getting 30 to 40 books
sent to me by publishers or authors per
week
that's that's impossible right you can't
even begin to
read those let alone have your own life
with your own priorities
if you suck if you bend to that type of
incoming so i
initially just said no no no no no no
no and they're all but even saying no
was exhausting
and took a lot of time when you start to
have not 30 40 a week but several
hundred a week
and uh i
then posted for instance a blog post
which is a
general policy of not reading any new
books in 2020 meaning
any books published in 2020. i've
extended that to 2021 i'm not reading
any books published in 2021 so when
someone asks me
or ask someone on my team they can say
ah sorry
tim's just not doing that he's got it
forward slash new books
yeah it depersonalizes it so it makes it
easier
to say no and it makes it easier for
other people to receive no
the the other thing is like if someone's
like hey let me send you blah blah blah
blah free product
free fill in the blank the first thing
you got to remember is like i remember
somebody said once
and i can't remember the attribution but
like free sex is the most expensive sex
you'll ever have right
that's true for free books that's true
for free
product it's not free there's gonna be
if you have an audience there's gonna be
a lot follow-up and sometimes it's like
oh my god
10 years later i've had 73 emails from
this person
don't open that door so if someone says
hey i'd love for you to try
x if it's a really close friend and i
know they're putting their like
reputation
on the line and putting some skin in the
game right they're risking something
then maybe but uh very rarely if it's a
book or something else i'm like you know
what i'll buy it myself
so how do you around the purchasing side
of it like how do you make a decision to
actually
buy something like how do you prevent
yourself from overspending on
items like is there anything that you
use to be more minimal
well i know you've you've had this
snooze function right where you won't
allow yourself to make the 3 a.m
amazon purchase you have to hit snooze
for 24 hours
yeah uh so this brings up
questions related to some
level of what people might consider
success right so you end up in
situations
and this is a very rarefied situation so
i want to acknowledge that
that up front like you and i are in very
fortunate positions
but let's say i get sent a bunch of [ __ ]
somehow it gets sent to me
and it's not useful to me i'm not
interested in it but it could be very
useful to someone else
let's take an easy example someone sends
me a bunch of swag
right like sweatshirts and hats and so
on it's like i have more
i have enough clothing to last me
forever i don't need any more t-shirts
none of it the cheapest thing for me to
do
is to throw that out right to literally
throw it in the trash
okay if i the the co then there are
karmically better things to do like
taking it to goodwill which is what i
usually do
and then i'm paying an assistant 20 30
40
an hour to do that right
i could return something
this is another consideration right like
am i actually going to return
something if i don't want it the answer
is likely no
yeah so i really try to measure twice
and cut once
in those cases
and i i think i am disinclined
to buy too many things right now
although if you looked at my
amazon order history that might sound
ridiculous
but compared to say even a few years ago
i buy
far fewer things because the
for me the visual punishment of having a
disordered
kitchen table of having a disordered
house
is so irritating i'm very visually
sensitive i'm kind of
like monk from the tv show in that way
i dislike that so much and i dislike
waste
so much uh this is particularly true of
food i'm
very sensitive to food waste uh
that it's it's sort of a
self self self-correcting
system in that way yeah i've become much
more sensitive to uh clutter
in the last few years yeah that makes
sense
all right let's move on to the next
question is there any advice
you used given to you or that you have
given
in the past that wasn't the best not
trying to be a troublemaker
i'm just wondering how high performers
know when to course correct
eg abandon faulty notions
that's a very good that's a yeah it does
make sense that's a very
good and it's a very important question
right because you always get advice from
people who
have done well or you see advice from
people who've done well
and there's a survivorship bias
right it's like the warren buffett
uh parable of sorts maybe it's not
parable maybe it's a
metaphor i always mix up metaphor and
analogy in any case
maybe it's a simile uh i could never
keep those straight but he talks about
if you take like 10 000 orangutans and
they're flipping quarters like
eventually you're gonna end up
with one orangutan who has like flipped
heads
a hundred times and then orangutan is
gonna write books about how to flip
quarters and
beat the stock market so there's so much
chance involved and there's such a
survivorship bias
meaning you only see the advertisements
for the
mutual funds that survive in a magazine
like barons or whatever
uh it's important to ask that question
and i'm i'm saying all of that to
buy myself some time because i know
those it must exist
i'll give one a good one
i had an incredible aversion to
any type of investment in publicly
traded equities
in stocks until just a few years ago
you know this you've watched this yeah
right were you telling people
not to invest in stocks or was this
something someone told you
so was it advice that you gave or advice
that you received because that was
advice
it was advice that i received
from a few people i respect who were
very uncomfortable in investing in
publicly traded equities because they
felt like they could not directly impact
the value of those companies
and these were startup investors
and that made a lot of sense to me at
the time
and that logic still makes sense right
like what am i going to do to
increase the the the market cap and the
the price per share of tesla right like
very
very little i mean i suppose my audience
is large enough that maybe for a day i
could like
register a blip maybe but really
not much and my thinking has
is become more nuanced right because the
argument that i can't have
a substantial impact on the price per
share therefore i shouldn't
invest is kind of two parts right so the
assumption that i can't have a
substantial impact on price per share
that's valid
but does that there therefore lead to
the conclusion
i should not invest i think there are
other considerations so
thinking about timeline right so if i'm
trying to invest in a company over six
months
i have zero confidence or very little
confidence
unless there is a huge drop for some
reason that i think is unwarranted
uh but if it's over a two three
year time horizon and i don't feel any
pressure to trade
then i've become much more comfortable
investing in a hand
excuse me a handful got the wine burps
already after one
class i feel much more comfortable
investing in a handful of companies
that i feel are kind of inevitable
unless they're grossly
mismanaged like from a from a tech trend
perspective they're kind of
inevitably going to do decently well
over a two to three year period so how
did you know when to course correct
though that that was
actually really interesting part of the
guy's question is like as a high
performer like
you know it's easy to get really kind of
into
someone's advice especially if it comes
from someone that's like super vetted
and you really believe in like
when did you decide like this is bad
advice
i need to change this yeah
you're good at this you should interview
people
so i i think it was forced upon me
in a way by covid in this particular
instance because
i was sitting in almost uh well i
shouldn't say entirely cash but
largely in cash like let's call it
just for the sake of argument 50 cash
yeah it was so dumb
well maybe well i mean when you're in
all cash you're losing
by just by inflation you're losing money
just literally no
well we could debate we could fight over
this one for a long time
i slept well at night for several years
because i had a huge because i had
a bed of cash and i don't think that
should be underestimated i don't think a
good
investment is a good investment if it
has
really high returns but you're like
sweating bullets within you
right and that's a very personal thing
so for me
having a lot of reserves in cash
helped me sleep i don't regret it
but when cobit hit and and right before
kovid hit and there was the gigantic
plummet i knew there was going to be a
plummet or i suspected
with high conviction there was going to
be a gigantic plummet
i was not savvy with options or credit
default swaps that was just not
on the menu for me but i thought they
were going to be
buying opportunities in many places and
so then the question was
well i've been sitting on the sidelines
i said i would be back
even in 2015. right now we have to be
aware of the sunk cost fallacy
not the cent cost fallacy but the
confirmation bias and all these various
things where it's like if i
publicly stated like when there's blood
in the streets i will be back and i will
invest
i said that in 2015 when i quote unquote
retired from startup investing
uh but i i deeply believed it i was like
this is i don't
as tim ferriss is the person who really
understands
very few aspects of investing with any
competence
i don't get a lot of fat pitches like
this and i was like
where am i going to put money like i
have all this money that i have claimed
i've been waiting to deploy
uh what the [ __ ] am i going to do with
and
i spoke with dozens of investors not
just two people i respected
and ultimately came to believe
very deeply in a few positions
whether or not kovit whether the
consequences
severe and also extended of covid
on both the economy and technology on
behavior were acute
or two three years long
companies i felt would would really
benefit in either scenario
so so i end the liquidity profile of
equities
right like you want to get out you can
get out you might get kicked in the
balls from a tax perspective etc but
you have liquidity unlike a lot of the
stuff that we do right like you
you put money in and like you are in
like your chips are on the table for you
know five to ten years we both have
examples that are way past ten years
yeah and um so that would be an example
uh but the example i think the
the example is interesting not because
equities not because the stock market
not because blah blah blah
it's it's the process right and i was
lucky to have a forcing function
uh i will say
here's another one right like i have
i've
really relied on dietary interventions
and exercise and so on for manipulating
my blood markers right my blood tests
for a long time and
if you look at my lipid profile so my
let's just say my cardiac and lipid
profile
it genetically speaking i have terrible
terrible
terrible software for a few things like
it doesn't matter if i'm vegan i've
tried that for a period of time just to
see what it did for my blood
it doesn't matter if i'm fasting i've
done tons of fasting pure keto
doesn't matter if i eat all meat i've
tried all these things and i've looked
at the blood tests
and my apo b count and various other
things are
terrible they're so bad you me both man
it sucks
yeah yeah and it's just like look i have
my dad's had a heart attack
uh my uncles have had
uh strokes and cardiac issues
this is a like we just got dealt a
really shitty hand
from a cardiac perspective and i've
never
considered going on medication like
ezetimibe is the one i'm considering
long term or indefinitely but after
doing
cardiac calcium scoring which is zero
currently but also
angiograms and all of these things that
are more uh
nuanced and provide more detail
i've kind of changed my tune i think
there is a point where the the
the risk benefit
ratio leads it leads one to the
conclusion that it makes sense right and
this is true with also like the vaccines
right
i think the code vaccines make
overwhelming sense
for a very high percentage of the
population
yeah uh so that would uh those be two
examples
yeah that's great awesome all right
another
question i'll let you try and guess who
this one is from uh
ends with akka when was the last time
when was the last time a blood or urine
sample was stored in your fridge
that's a good one uh because there was a
time
when you open up your fridge and it's
like a six pack of beer there's just
urine everywhere
like this yeah there's urine blood stool
samples were the best with the bio
hazard
marker on it yeah you have to be very
careful in the ferrous household
you also you all you also really don't
want to take any supplements until you
confirm that the label
corresponds to what is actually in the
bottle you do it
i remember i went to your classroom i
was in your house i went to the bathroom
one time
and like i don't know you had the
cupboard open or some [ __ ] and i look up
and it's like it's like a freaking
walgreens dude like you had
thousands of supplements i was like how
does he take all this stuff i
guess you just were accumulating over
time yeah it's been accumulated over
time i
i also have dramatically reduced the
number of supplements that i take but
all right so as far as blood uh blood
and
urine samples go i haven't stored any of
that
in the refrigerator for a long time now
doesn't mean that i haven't taken
samples so the last time i took
let's see blood and urine samples i mean
within the last two weeks
or three weeks within the last three
weeks but i you
i have realized during covid that there
is such a thing
called mobile phlebotomy so you can
rather than going into quest or one of
these labs to have a draw performed or
into your doctor's office there
are in fact services or people who
provide
mobile blood draws so you can set an
appointment you can even meet them
outside
and literally it's like you wake up you
probably do not eat breakfast but you
wake up
you're fasting and you have a blood draw
within
five to ten minutes they're actually not
that expensive either i looked in i had
one
happen here in oregon and it was like 50
bucks to have it done
and yeah it's fantastic like what what a
especially during covet dude you don't
want to be around
like 15 other people in a room yeah
it's amazing i i
i have found it to be a godsend and
really really convenient
a mobile phlebotomist for people are
wondering how it's spelled flabatomist
is p-h-p-h-l
phlebotomist with a bunch of e's and o's
and other wheel fortune
ingredients all right all right uh i
will say though that
people wanted us to get a lot of the
comments was they get personal like get
into it
i i will tell one other little story
when i when i was leaving your house
that one time remember this is a long
time ago it's like a decade ago or
something
you you're like you're like okay like
most friends they say like goodbye like
you know give you a hug or whatever fist
bump whatever
you like hand me like you're like all
right dude like have a good one like and
you hand me like a
a bottle of beef liver pills do you
remember this
oh those are great i'm like okay cool
friend thanks for the beef flavor
you didn't even tell me what to do with
them it's like hey take some beef liver
on your way out
yeah those were that's desiccated beef
liver
uh from grass-fed cows in argentina i
remember that
yeah those i had a friend who was uh
def he was deficient in all sorts of
things i gave him those
and he took them and he's like i feel
like i'm on crack like i have so much
energy
that i cannot even begin to understand
how tired i was for so long
so yes do you remember what brand that
was
offhand i don't i don't either it's on
amazon i know that i ordered it on
amazon
nice so all right caveat emptor beware
your
not all beef liver pills are created
equal
yeah you don't want like nasty hormone
injected beef liver pills like don't
no no all right so uh going a little bit
more sensitive
i wish we had like some background music
that we could play while this kicks in
i i bet i bet we can figure out some
background yeah that's like a like
we'll make it happen sweet you have the
resources um
how how did you meet and fall in love
with your girlfriend
just a quick note from the editor in
post-production this is tim i had to cut
part of this one for privacy reasons
but i love you all very much now back to
our show
which is a strong hand like that's
that's uh that's that's a good move
and i was very interested so texted her
we had a drink
we met up and the rest is history that's
amazing
that was quite a few years ago so let me
ask you a question though
uh because i gotta your fans are gonna
want this i have to do it i apologize
tim
uh it says in the the actual question
fall in love
so when was the like like for me you
know you talked about with when i met
daria at the bar we talked about zelda
and she was a big zelda fan i was like
oh my god i could love this girl like
was there something that jumped out
during that first couple dates we were
just like this girl could be
an amazing match for me oh it was
it and again what were the traits like
was there anything that you jumped out
is like a
a common movie like something she said
that was funny like what was it that
that like started to check those boxes
for you you know it was none of that
it was none of the
the data points or
things she said like oh we have that in
common oh our values are aligned
it was more of a feeling like i felt
very at ease with her i felt like i
didn't need to have my defenses up
i felt like there were i was very
confident there were no
ulterior motives that is the hugest
thing for you dude that's
awesome yeah yeah i just felt very
comfortable and she was so
playful and funny
and light basically all the things i'm
not most of the time
and ah
she also gave me so much energy you know
what i'm talking about like that's a big
deal yeah right like
there are people who drain your energy
and they're people who give you energy
and there are people some people are
maybe neutral but
i think over time as you interact with
more people as you get older
certainly as you develop an audience of
any type you become much more sensitive
to that
because you're much more exposed to it
yeah and
she just gave me so much energy i mean
it was such a net
positive for my state of being
and i think that drove it and yes we
ended up having all these values in
common
yes we ended up having lots of
priorities and interests in common but
that was secondary
to the feeling that's so cool that you
know one of the things that
you know you know i've talked about
privately a lot that i think is worth
mentioning you can always cut it out
like you do
by the way just so people know you've
cut out some [ __ ] out of previous
podcasts
i don't cut this out well i want to tell
people there
are no for some very good legal reasons
in some cases but yes continue so i was
just going to say that um i
i love that she brings down like the
brought the anxiety level down for you
because one of the things that
that i know is is tough for for almost
probably anybody that
has some some fame and fortune as you
have it's like
there are so many people that would date
you
you know because of your quote unquote
tim ferriss and like
there's there's money in fame that goes
along with that right so you could go to
la
and you there's any number of people i'm
sure that you could date because of
those reasons
and because of that i know you've had a
pretty pretty big wall like you put up a
wall
to protect yourself because that's not
what you want you want someone long-term
you don't want just like some rando
and it's cool that she no it's cool that
she brought that down though that that's
a huge thing
for you to find i'm happy about that
yeah i'm happy about it too
thrilled about it it's uh it's [ __ ]
weird
you know having uh you know meeting
people who let's just say eight times
out of ten have googled your name
beforehand that's [ __ ] weird yeah
it's really really strange and you have
to be very careful
because let's not kid ourselves like
there are a lot of sharks out there
yeah um so yeah it's been it's been
it's been really nice and her parents
are amazing i've spent a lot of time
with her parents and
she's very down to earth and by down to
earth
i say that in the most complementary way
possible
right like by down to earth like
it makes me think of uh i think his name
is donald
knuth k-n-u-t-h but at some point he
disavowed email i think he was at ibm
i might be making that up and he said
email is great
for keeping on top of things he's like
but i don't want to keep on top of
things i want to get to the bottom of
things
i'm paraphrasing here but people who are
down to earth from my perspective
are like getting to the bottom of things
they're
they're aware of like the tectonic plate
level
of things moving and their awareness
is much more grounded i use that word
again
in what i would consider a true
reality than a lot of the people who are
higher up in the stack right of
abstraction
so there's a computer science analogy
here but i won't belabor that because
i'll just embarrass myself
the point being i felt like she really
had
her feet on the ground and was
paying attention to the important things
she had an awareness
including a self-awareness perhaps
principle
among all of those that led me to feel
very comfortable
right but when people are surfing the
chop right when they're on the surface
and it's like
whatever's trending on twitter is
directing their attention for hours a
day
even if they're on some level at their
core
really good people it makes them a
liability
does that make sense because they're so
easily swayed
to one channel or direction
or meme or hashtag or movement
or crisis like that's a very
unpredictable person
i was on cue that was good i like that
the phone's ringing i don't know why oh
he called me twice sorry he get pushed
through
just keep going no problem was who was
that was that your
bail bonds tony conrad just freaking
called multiple times
[ __ ] tony conrad podcast
god damn it tony's a good friend
so i feel free to give him [ __ ] if you
guys actually want to
just as a side note uh research a really
good
early stage investor who's a good dude
and
really likes his coffee and he will tell
you about blue bottle so be prepared
you should check out twenty conrad he's
a good guy also a partner at your firm
he's a he's a colleague a co-worker he's
done some good deals he's got a great
eye
um right so uh let's move on to the next
question
name a mistake you made in one of your
books that you wish you could take back
there has to be something don't say
there is no i don't know oh there's
gotta be something i mean there are
probably hundreds of them
uh my books are [ __ ] long i mean you
have so many options i mean the
four-hour body there had to be something
like the
consumption of horse urine or there was
something in there that you have well
i mean there was one mistake that i
pulled out so in the first edition of
the four-hour body there's a whole
chapter on extended breath holds
and i realize that's just too dangerous
people don't understand the safety
precautions you need to take for breath
holds
and it was yanked so that didn't
actually make it to press
yeah it made it depressed for one
printing that was a david blaine chapter
talking about how he trained me to hold
my breath for like five minutes and
i realized that you just have to assume
that
90 of the people out there aren't going
to read any of the safety caution nary
tales right they're not going to read
the
caveats they're not going to read the
preamble they're going to skip straight
to the how to and it's
it's it's very dangerous so that was one
how about any of the science because the
science changes so fast is there
anything you look back on and you're
like oh gosh that's just not accurate
anymore
well i will say there was a weight loss
stack of supplements called pag
which was polycosinol probably
mispronouncing that but i've only read
it never
heard it said in fact alpha lipoic acid
uh garlic extract like allicin
and green tea extract
preferably decaffeinated and of that
stack
the most suspect or questionable of
those
is the first polycosinol and there are
some studies that came
out of cuba but i mean like how much can
you trust that if they're exporting
sugar cane and blah blah blah blah
so i would say if i were to put anything
on the chopping block
it would probably be polycosinol and
really the evidence for that
from an nf1 perspective was my own
personal experience there seemed to be
some effect on cholesterol
or lipid metabolism with polycastinol
that increased fat loss
above and beyond that which i was able
to achieve with agg
but that is not doubly blinded that is
not randomized that's not
placebo-controlled
so but the ala is in there for fat loss
right
uh yeah so yeah alpha lipoic acid is
insulin omimetic as i understand it it
it
it imitates uh and produces some
analogous
effect to insulin on a lesser
to a lesser degree so alpha lipoic acid
is interesting
if you over consume it it can cause all
sorts of issues
which is true of a lot of things like
you ever consume zinc it can inhibit
copper absorption like you have to be
very careful with supplements
which is part of the reason why i have
really reduced the number of supplements
that i consume well
this is a great segue that question
actually is like what what do you
consume these days in terms of
supplements
not much uh i i take zinc occasionally
i do find it to help sleep i do find it
to help
lucid dream induction which we've talked
about before
i find zinc interesting also from an
immune perspective but if you overtake
it or you take it too consistently it
can cause
all sorts of issues i take
right now b12 and
l-methylfolate uh
gyros specifically that is your
homocysteine levels or is that
that why yeah yeah related to
homocysteine so that
is dependent on my personal blood
profile
so that doesn't mean everyone listening
to this should take that right
and i also am taking
right now cystis quadrangularis
which kind of has a funny tie-in to us
actually
and uh also methyl sulfatal
methane or msm i'm taking both of those
because i'm nursing a wrist injury
and i found them to be very helpful with
joint
uh injuries or like connective tissue
ligament
tendon issues so cystis quadrangularis
is what i took on during our trip to
china i took alpha lipoic acid and
sisus s-i-s-s-u-s
quadrangularis you'll figure it out i
took those two together
before every meal because we were eating
pounds of [ __ ] rice
every day yeah and i would be doing
workouts
in my like skivvies with my backpack you
remember that
once you see tim ferriss in his
underwear doing air squats in front of
your bed
like you cannot unsee that [ __ ]
and you said something to the effect of
like we were i said quit doing
your [ __ ] underwear well well there
was that
there was that for sure and then there
was also like
we're just getting fatter and fatter and
you're getting more and more rich that's
what the [ __ ] is going on that was the
most confusing part because we were like
a weekend in the trip and
and glenn and i are just fat as [ __ ]
from all that that the rice
and you're like six packs are popping
out it was crazy
yeah so i'm taking that stuff again but
not for the fat loss
for the uh the the potential joint
assistance
wrists are a huge pain in the ass i i
jacked my wrist
really badly and i want to get back into
handstand
practice uh so i'm eager to get it
figured out
all right uh actually leading i want to
stay on that for one more quick topic
um someone was asking how is your body
these days
you talked about your wrist but um these
are three questions real quick
do you still practice for our body and
what is your pro approach to longevity
so
is there any practices that you're doing
now on the longevity side kind of
transitioning out out of the i just put
need to put mass on but more on the
want to live longer yeah i would say
those are probably inverse
inversely proportionate right right the
more you try to put mass on the the
shorter you're probably making your life
um if you're doing over an extended
period of time at least
but uh i would say body
like i'm not in great shape right now
i've had a bunch of injuries
which just goes to show like it's i
think it's better to have a few
extra percentage points of body fat and
more strength
than to be lean and sacrifice strength i
think right now i've sacrificed strength
for a bunch of reasons i'm in the jungle
i'm
eating pretty poorly and
not getting much in terms of resistance
training
in and
so i would say body overall right now is
pretty achy
and i'll fix that i have high degree of
confidence that i can fix it so i'm not
worried about it
which leads to the four hour body piece
i still follow a surprising amount of
what was in the four hour body
if anything the vast majority of the for
our body
that was viewed very skeptically was
received very poorly
has accrued an incredible amount of
scientific support
in the last 10 years because i was
published in 2010 so i'm i am very
proud of the four hour body like that
was kind of the tip of the spear
with a bunch of areas that has uh only
received
more support in the last 10 years so i'm
very happy with that and
i would say uh
the the general tenets still hold
uh for sure so from from the perspective
of
slow cadence weightlifting a la occam's
protocol
i probably wouldn't be eating the same
food because i'm not trying to gain mass
but using that type of slow cadence or
super slow protocol
to add muscle mass while minimizing
injury potential
absolutely i'll be doing a bunch of that
uh
and then there's a bunch of stuff from
from
tools of titans so let's not forget the
tools of titans was basically
my update to four hour work week for our
body and for our chef simultaneously
there's a bunch of stuff in tools of
titans related to say glute medius
training
related to gymnastic strength training
and so on
acro yoga that i view as a really
important component of
what i do these days for uh
physical longevity yeah meaning
like how old you feel i think is how old
your joints feel
very often and aside from that though
like with the longevity stuff like am i
using
metformin no am i using rapamycin
no would i consider it maybe
at some point but the most likely thing
to kill me is heart disease
so really i can focus on so-called
longevity drugs
but for me personally those longevity
drugs might take the form of something
like an azedum
probably not a statin due to the fact
that i am a hyper absorber
of cholesterol not necessarily a hyper
producer
so you need to get really uh deliberate
and surgical about how you approach
medication
and none of this is medical advice
should not be construed as medical
advice
uh since who the [ __ ] am i but
um so talk to your gp but i think
the obsession this is gonna upset some
people but the obsession over longevity
is is often very misplaced
like i look i i looked at one point at
the average
life spans of males in my family on both
the paternal and maternal lines
and if they didn't die really really
early
which they clearly didn't because they
lasted long enough to procreate but if
they didn't get wiped out by like
typhoid
fever in you know at age 35 or something
in the 1800s
pretty much all of them die at 85. they
die around 85.
[ __ ] everybody and it doesn't matter
if it's
you know 20 years ago or 300 years
85 is a good run dude that's not that
bad it's not that bad so as far as
yeah so as far as as the as you know
pulling straws like i didn't get the
short straw i didn't get the short test
draw
but it is striving for immortality i'm
glad there are people who are
preoccupied by it and are spending time
on it
all things equal which is never the case
by the way but all things equal would i
prefer to live to 120 versus
85 yeah why not sure but
am i gonna do caloric restriction every
day so my testosterone falls through the
floor and like i lose all my muscle mass
and i look like a [ __ ] prisoner of
war
no i'm not gonna do that yeah uh
yeah so i i don't spend a lot of time
thinking about longevity
per se or ultra long lifespan i
do spend time thinking about what stupid
mistakes i can prevent
easily or what medications or
supplements or interventions i can
implement
easily that will prevent me from dying
earlier than i should based on my
genetic average
yeah that makes a lot of sense i mean
that's the whole peter attila thing
which i think is
beautiful just really digs in the family
history and says what are the things
you're going to die from and let's
prevent those from happening you know
yeah yeah totally it's like for the you
know the
focus on the fundamentals focus on the
basics
next question best movie to watch
mushroom on mushrooms
[Laughter]
oh that's a good one i you know i it
depends a lot on the dose
it depends a lot on the toast like if
you're micro dosing you can handle one
type of movie
if you're on like three grams of
mushrooms just look at the walls
just [ __ ] chill out and look at a
flower because it's gonna you know
three three grams is actually navigable
for a pretty decent percent of the
population but like five
six grams just lay down later yeah
just lay down and listen to some really
cheesy spa music
and [ __ ] relax because it's gonna be
an interesting six hours but but let's
just say hypothetically that someone has
taken
600 milligrams three to six hundred
milligrams of philosophy mushrooms dried
i would say spirited away oh
arguably my favorite movie of all time
the animated movie spirited away
will [ __ ] blow your mind and
if if that isn't interesting
i think uh soundtrack is important to
pay attention to do not watch something
even if it's beautiful like baraka
if it has a weird moody soundtrack that
may not be good for you
so i would say
something my predisposition would be
something animated
like lilo and stitch or
how to train your dragon you know
something like that
if you try to get too fancy if you're
like i'm going to watch a moody black
and white french film
you're just asking to get [ __ ] kicked
in the nuts yeah
when i was a kid it was pink floyd the
wall that's but that was just not that
was not mushrooms that was weed
so i think that'd be a little too
intense for too intense or mushy
different
yeah different yeah yeah my i would say
pay attention to soundtrack when in
doubt pay attention to soundtrack
all right uh next question what is
something you have failed at
but haven't spoken of people just want
to know about your failures
yeah they want all the likes
episode number 500 the low light rail
uh let's see something i've failed at
but
haven't talked about has there you know
you did this you did this series where
you went and did a bunch of episodes you
know
you hacked things really quickly and
you're you're so good at like consuming
books and like getting to the meat of
what something is and figuring it out
there has to be something where you were
just like i want to figure this out and
you just [ __ ] suck at it right like
well i mean honestly episode one of the
tim ferriss experiment
when i did parkour which was my
insistence
i was like we're gonna do parkour first
episode one
and i [ __ ] myself up
so badly i mean i had so many injuries
like
elbow wrist knee i tore
three of my four quadriceps these are
your thigh muscles from
like quadriceps four right i
tore severely tore three of them from
impact from jumping off of stuff
it was a [ __ ] disaster like an
unmitigated disaster
and i don't think i talked to i've
talked about that much and so
i insisted with in retrospect the most
idiotic reasoning ever that we would do
parkour first
and what that meant was we had 13
episodes to film we were filming every
[ __ ] week without a vacation
for 13 weeks straight and the first week
i basically became a [ __ ]
like i [ __ ] ruined myself it was so
bad
and so you know for weeks afterwards i'm
wearing like
medical grade compression pants which
take like
an hour to get on it's like if you
imagine you're a three i'm not a 300
pound guy but just imagine you're like a
300 pound guy
and you have like elastic gap kids
[ __ ] long underwear that you have to
get on it takes
forever like it takes so long and there
are points
i've definitely not talked about this
where i was so [ __ ] up after that
parkour episode
and i'd be wearing these like
compression pants just to function to
like hobble around like a pirate
for you know whatever i was filming
episode two three four
and i would get so tired and they took
like 45 minutes to get off
maybe an exaggeration but they took
[ __ ] forever to get off it'd be like
an extra small
wetsuit that you have to get off your
legs and i would be so tired that i'd be
like
i'd get it down to like my mid-calf and
i'd be like [ __ ] it and i would just lay
down on the bed like with
with these with these compression pants
around my ankles or my
uh my shins unable to get them off i
would just sleep
i would just sleep with these things
around my ankles so
that's one that comes to mind that's a
good there are many
yeah there are many there are many but
that's that's a colorful one it's
amazing
uh what okay when it happens what type
of dad do you want to be
oh that's a big one when it happens what
kind of dad do i want to be
you got to leave the space gap in here
when we had the episode
yeah it's good yeah he's thinking he's
thinking everybody i'm watching
it's like watching a dog trying to
figure out a maze uh
i i you know i i think that the first
i'll go with the first two that come to
mind i just want to be really present
and really engaged
and and loving obviously uh
but i i
just want to really [ __ ] pay
attention
and be engaged because i know so
many guys including good friends of mine
who are just like yeah man i'm
[ __ ] missed it like they grew up so
quickly and like
you missed two years it's like missing
20 years
so i want to be really present and
really engaged
i think it's yeah if i pay attention to
that i feel like all the tactical
sleep training versus the attachment
versus whatever like i can figure that
all out but if you don't have the
prerequisite
attention and awareness and engagement
than
none of that i mean all that stuff is
winter dressing i feel like
when i think about being a father i
think about
some of the attributes that my own dad
had that were amazing and i would
certainly want to continue those on and
then other little tweaks i'd want to do
because you know that's what we're doing
we're kind of pushing things forward
what attributes would you say did you
really enjoy from your father and there
are any little tweaks that you would
make
you know i think my parents did
a great job considering
the circumstances that we found
ourselves in
right i mean i think a lot like you we
didn't have very much money
you know there's there was not budget
for new bikes and
stuff like that uh we made everything go
a long way
lots of tv dinners lots of tv
i was there too yep yeah man
yeah god there were there was there was
the good the bad and the ugly with the
tv dinners
like those shitty brownies were so
delicious the shitty shitty like
brownies in the middle square at the top
those are so good
um and the fried chicken was good but
some of the some of the tv dinner is not
so great we did a lot of beauty more
beef stew in my house that was good
nice i love that you know and and there
were all these special moments
like uh the some of the celebratory
and if something big happened and we had
a celebratory dinner we'd go to red
lobster i'm a red lobster we'd have
we'd have virgin daiquiris and
immediately get brain freeze and then
eat those
fried mozzarella sticks
and they were so [ __ ] good so
you know like i feel like my parents did
a really good job
on a lot of levels uh
i will have the benefit of more time
right so if i if
i in any way say i don't have time
or i feel like i don't have time i just
want to plant the seed now that that is
utter horseshit right like we make
time for the things that matter and
i'm in a much better position than my
parents were
uh financially did your dad work a lot
did he travel a lot or work a lot or
what was it i travel a lot you know my
my mom and dad
worked a lot and
uh i'm good at working
right like you and i are both good at
playing
certain games and it's very challenging
for me at least to sit on the sidelines
or switch games
when you've spent so much time getting
good at certain games
yeah so
yeah that's part of the reason i'm in
the middle of nowhere right now is to
just create a little bit of space and
and prevent myself from over committing
to a bunch of new projects
just because i have a void
or a vacuum and
uh i'm excited
about the you know fatherhood about
being a parent
i'm excited for you i think it's good
it's gonna be a fun fun chapter
uh long chapter long chapter yeah the
longest chapter
especially at our age man i just think
the thing i think about is just like
when our kids are 21 we're gonna be so
old
it's like gonna be crazy yeah we're
gonna be we're gonna be really old you
and i can go to the park with walkers
together
exactly um all right next question from
this is i had to say the name because
this is a tweet from
huns conduit so some guy's using his
business account
do he has this guy runs conduit which is
great
uh tim famously asks his guest about a
message that would hypothetically
plaster on a billboard
uh will you ask him about his current
message what would your current
billboard message be
you know i don't my message is still the
same
it hasn't changed much and that is and i
i've borrowed this from other people but
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most
yeah that's a great one like like
wherever you spend a lot
of time with like you are going to
absorb
and vice versa right they're going to
absorb you so
really be aware of that like physically
emotionally
psychologically financially
yeah that's so true i've just seen it
confirmed over and over and over and
over again for me and for other people
yeah that's a great one i don't think
you can get better than that one that's
great
uh next question from ryan hair
transplant question mark
would you do a hair transplant no
not at this point they have the
technology has come a long way do not
knock that right away
because there are there's it looks
really good i have a couple friends that
have done it they're not gonna be named
here but it can it could look amazing
uh look i mean here's my perspective
there is one reason
for me to get hair transplant if it's by
the way if this is financial i will pay
for your hair transplant i'm going to do
that right now
i'm serious i'm serious i will pay for
it right now go on the record
do i need kev kev like etched in the
side like kitten play style
exactly uh
i number one i'm very fortunate to have
a reasonably regular uh
dome so i don't have a whole lot of
moguls
on my skull um and i don't
mind being bald i don't i
really don't mind it and i think i led
into it easily by
starting to shave my head when i was
like 12 13 and wrestling
so i'm accustomed to it the second thing
is i would get
so much [ __ ] from
people forever if i had some weave like
i don't know if you've ever seen hellboy
but there's that one guy who has hair
implants
and it just looks like kendall uh
i would get so much more [ __ ] yeah it's
too late and i currently
do i would be disinclined
and then you know third and i think i
was saying this earlier and i cut myself
off it's like
why do guys care i think 99 times out of
100 it's because
they they want to have they want to be
more attractive to women or get laid
more often by having hair like period
full stop i don't care i don't care
about that
right like i'm very very happy
with my girlfriend we're planning on
having a family together and
like if if i couldn't be with someone
because i didn't have hair i don't want
to be with them in the first place like
that's your
that's that's a that's a very charitable
easy layup yellow or red flag for any
guy
oh by the way you did the right thing
like the wrong thing
is leaving like the sides on and just
kind of going with the bald top
like the power donut right exactly
yeah you know i'm not look there are a
few people who can pull that off
like if you're uh what's his name
commander picard or whatever
star trek like if if you're somebody
that badass
you can pull off the power donut if
you're a like a hedge fund manager just
just
give zero [ __ ] and as a master of the
universe and you're just like look i can
i can move global
global markets and decimate currencies
with one twitch of my pinky finger
great then like keep the power donut i
do not have the confidence or the
wherewithal or the skill set or the
power
to make that work for me so well it
looks great it's nice and shiny right
now
the light's hitting in the right
direction it's beautiful has a has a
hell
has a healthy sheen to it like a dog
coat
all right moving on to the next question
uh
your favorite episode in why
and and i will say that with the caveat
that we we you know
you can mention the one that you you
talked about that was really
really dear to you that you did a few
episodes back but
i think outside of that particular
episode about the the around the abuse
yeah i mean favorite episode is is i get
this question
quite a bit it's hard to give a favorite
episode because
almost all of my episodes have some
personal driver behind them
so the reason i do episodes vary so
widely
that there is objectively no
one best even subjectively there is no
one
best uh it has everything to do with
what my goals
or challenges might be at any given
point in time uh
i think let me ask you two questions
hold on let me ask you two questions i
think we can
hone this in a little bit favorite
fanboy episode meaning i oh my god i
can't believe i have this person on my
podcast
and then i'd also love to know i i know
who it is it's hugh jackman isn't it
am i right hugh jackman is super high up
uh that that was definitely a huge one
uh arnold schwarzenegger was the first
like gigantic
fanboy episode uh jamie foxx
another one i mean those three episodes
are also
killer like they weren't just fanboy
encounters but they were
really strong episodes yeah really
really strong episodes
so fanboy moments there are a ton of
them i mean i've spoken with so many
people i never thought i would ever have
any interaction with jerry seinfeld
um i mean it's a long list it's a long
long list but
certainly hugh jackman is
way up there arnold schwarzenegger way
up there jamie foxx and
uh jerry and so many others
those are a few how about someone that
just really surprised you or you're like
oh i i should have this person on then
you had them on you're like god damn
that was a good episode
there are so many they give you give me
a couple of these he doesn't have to be
one
yeah i love i love the fanboy episodes
but those those are names that people
automatically know i mean they're
household names right
uh bj miller who's a hospice charisma
uh physician and i think the episode it
was titled something like bj miller the
man who's helped a thousand plus people
to die something like that
that episode had a huge impact on me
still does uh
then you have people like mary carr
who's an author and very well known
memoir writer
and teacher who's just incredible that
episode is pretty recent
carr k-a-r-r she was incredible
let's see here honestly i mean i have to
mention again but just like
there are certain episodes like jamie
foxx or hugh jackman where you're like
holy [ __ ] i hope my equipment is working
yeah it's just so [ __ ] good and
you're like oh my god if this fails i
will just have to throw myself out a
window i mean
when i even when i interviewed elon musk
uh my show i was like
please do not fail hard drive like you
know because we're like
recording it yeah yeah yeah totally
totally it was great yeah there's so
there are
there are those moments for sure what
was it like for you to interview elon
i've never we've never talked about it
it i mean he's
he's a really cool guy he was super
friendly and
i've met him a couple times at various
parties and stuff and he's always been
really nice to me i think he knew
me from back in the dig days when i
created dig or you know he was it wasn't
it was clear to me that it wasn't just
some like he had heard of some stuff i
had created which was nice because that
gives you a little bit of an in and a
way to have a conversation
um i loved it i thought it was a lot of
fun i mean i
i tried to ask him some questions that
um
were just uh a little bit like not the
ones a standard reporter would ask
and so um he had a good time with it we
just talked about like
i i always like to go really really back
to his childhood and like some of the
entrepreneurial kind of moments he had
growing up and
some of the things he was a fan of and
some of the comic books what he was into
like nobody talks about that you know
but he talks about his favorite comic
books on my my show like
stuff like that so it was yeah it was a
it was a really
we talked about spacex and some of the
stuff that he was doing with with
hyperloop before it was announced
um yeah it was it was awesome obviously
he's
quite the icon these days this was a
couple years ago so
yeah yeah that tony stark
totally in the flesh um all right
moving on to the next episo our next
episode the next question
um what do you think about all the
recent government ufo footage
is it real
do well believe in ufos i don't i don't
know if it's real
uh in the sense do i know i don't know
if the footage is real
i've read way too much about
uh you know well documented programs
like
mk ultra with the cia and so i mean the
like it's it's very hard to know what is
propaganda and what is not
what is the mk ultra what is that uh
this is this is
sort of uh the the
deliberate and non-consensual
administration of lsd by
the cia as a possible truth serum or
destabilizing
agent and all sorts of craziness
and you know i've also looked very
closely at the stargate program which
was
utilizing remote viewers or those
considered to be remote viewers
remote perception and all this craziness
so like are ufos real
[ __ ] i don't know i will say this
that's a big question above my pay grade
uh i will say this though that
there are a few places on long island
that are
fairly well known
by locals for
having what some people consider ufo
sightings
and when i was a kid on long island i
and a whole car full of people
including like a babysitter and some
other people
us all saw some weird object like fly
across
the sky hover for a period of time kind
of bounce around and then
shoot off at speeds it made no sense so
was that an illusion
was it caused by some type of
weather pattern right like the
lights of marfa in texas are supposedly
created by some type of phenomenon that
can be explained
meteorologically was it that
was it test flights with some type of
aircraft
being performed by the government which
are unknown unannounced
was it some type of
aircraft from elsewhere i mean either
way it is an unidentified flying object
so do i believe in ufos yeah i believe
in ufos
are they aliens
[ __ ] if i know like i have no idea but
i mean i i i remain open to the
possibility
yeah all right let's move on to the next
question this one is a little bit
this one's a little bit harder than last
uh have you ever tried viagra
if so thoughts
[Applause]
[Laughter]
these were gonna get yeah intimate yeah
this is great yeah this is great
so uh i i have tried viagra
i've tried i've tried everything i mean
i've tried just about everything
minus heroin and
i actually had a really scary response
to a small amount
of viagra which was i got a shooting
pain
like a axe pick in the brain pain
from taking it which has made me
contraindicated from
taking i don't know if viagra is a
what is it a phosphodiesterase inhibitor
of some type
but i have to be very careful with that
stuff because in
a small percentage of the population you
can have these
massively uh powerful adverse
events um does that apply to all of like
cialis and stuff like that or is that
just viagra
i don't i don't know i'm not i'm not
sure
did it did it oh oh the viagra i mean
well yeah i mean not to get too graphic
here but yeah it was [ __ ] fantastic i
mean that stuff
why the hell do you think it's so
popular like yeah it works as advertised
it's like why do
athletes use anabolic steroids because
they [ __ ] work right i mean like
there are certain drugs that really
deliver as advertised yeah
you just have to be aware of the
possible side effects i had a really
weird experience with that stuff that
stuff is strange
uh well hold on you can't let that hang
no what well i just feel like it's
well i'm sure we're a couple glasses of
wine in trying to ride that fine line
so i'm going to say this in a very pc
way the best i can at this moment in
time don't say in a pc way well
absolutely here's the deal okay so when
you take it
you know 30 minutes later it kicks in
and you can tell by like you feel like a
flushedness in your face did you get
that that kind of like
like tingly flushes in your face i got a
flush mess in my sh
in my shirt okay so that's enough so
what happens next
is things elevate and and when they do
so
it's like at the um it's like blowing a
blue balloon to like 12 when it should
be at a 10.
and you reach down no no when you reach
down it feels like it's another dude's
thing because it's like it's way
bigger than you you're used to
right because you're the knob has gone
to a 12.
so it's it's just confusing that's all
it but it does
it does make it does make you like a
you're a dragon slayer for a couple
hours
at least like it's there's no
you'd agree with that though right yeah
i would
i think dragon slaying on viagra is
definitely gonna have to make it into
the headline of this episode
it is it is a weird thing it is
definitely a weird thing i bought mine
in mexico of all places
this is like yeah you got to be careful
yeah you got to be careful who knows
like if it was like an
amplified dose or something but yeah uh
kind of insane
it could have been clorox who knows
exactly
all right uh any other four-hour books
in the future
none planned i have are you done are you
you're done with the four hour
yeah i think so that's fair that's fair
rest in peace for an hour the four hour
thing was it was fun for me
yeah remember i used to i used to send
you i you sent you texts of like the
four there was a four hour london
laundry cleaner in uh sf and i always do
i'd like to walk by you take photos
i like take photos of it and send it to
tim
ness or something that's remember that
yeah yeah definitely yeah no i have
thank you for your service four hour i
think uh i am
i'm done it's it's it's it's retired as
a jersey
framed on the wall nice what a beautiful
chapter
and it was a chapter that was a good
chapter good couple chapters
it was um all right so what will you be
doing at age 50 and 60
[Music]
that was the actual question yeah
so just retirement i don't know why they
picked those years but like let's just
say later in life like
give me what does tim tim look like 20
30 years from now
yeah you know retirement i don't think
that's a thing yeah
i i just i i sort of enjoy
getting amongst it too much i i can't
imagine like just like sitting around
doing so
sudoku all day watching wheel of fortune
or something like i just
i don't think that's going to be me so
50 or 60 i mean uh let's see i'm this i
mean
it's not that far off 50 you know i'm
43. how old are you right now
43. [ __ ] hey man 44 7 years away
i know it's crazy one turning of the
locusts
and we're 50. so uh 50
i mean let's just say i have like you
know six or seven year old kid
at that point um
i will probably be in increasingly
cantankerous and salty uh
i will be increasingly
uninterested in social consensus
or social media or
i mean i feel like that's you popularity
i don't think this
yeah i think it'll just be like tim plus
it'll be like tim tim plus
love it uh i think there's i think
there's a good chance that i will be
spending
more months of the year with the family
in and surrounded by nature
less time in urban environments from an
athletic
perspective i would i would anticipate
to still be doing things like acroyoga
skiing probably weight training at least
once per week i think they'll become
more and more and more important
uh
still i will be paying deep attention to
and supporting psychedelic research and
other aspects of that type of medicine
work
i got it's hard for me to envision like
a huge
change aside from focus on family which
i think will be
yeah a gigantic shift but
uh you know i
i would hope not to have to contend with
any major
medical emergencies or crises in my
family but
tbd i mean 60 if i'm 60
you know that could be at the point
where my parents want to both pass which
will be a huge transition
i don't know how that will affect me
it's impossible to predict
for me i just i just don't know i don't
even have a point of reference
yeah uh let's move on to the next
question we've got a couple more left
and then we can wrap things up
uh and i do have some extra bonus ones
if you want to keep going but
um bonus don't do it i'm all for well
let's just do
the last saka or a quick soccer one uh
what what's your quote-unquote holy [ __ ]
today
sucked drink or drug of choice
that's from saka
that's a great one
[Laughter]
well it depends on at what time of the
day i determine that the day has already
sucked
so if it's well hold on
so if if it if i wake up and i'm just
getting [ __ ] hay makers
for like the first two hours of the day
and i'm like wow like today is
already sucking donkey dick this is
terrible
then we i might just [ __ ] call it and
have a day of mushrooms and walk
through the forest and just think i'm
done tap
i am complete so that that's one
i would say otherwise
the the one that is ill-advised
for me is drinking copious amounts
of caf of caffeine right having just
like four or five
six cups of coffee which on the way up
on the way up feels so good and you get
so manic and like you forget all your
worries
and then the coin flips and you just
feel like an anxious mess on the way
down so that's
that's a mixed blessing for sure i would
say
uh gin and soda
like a hendrix and soda or
casa dragones like a tequila and soda
at like dusk so
these days like a 5 30 kind of happy
hour like you know what
i'm not gonna try to like squeak this
out and
grind for another hour hour and a half
like
nope gonna call this one at 4 30.
five if it's really brutal if you're
just like
why like if i if if i'm still in the
game i'm just like
limping along with the ball getting
crushed by like 500 pound linebackers
like yeah
what am i doing this for this is
pointless i'd say
gin and soda what was the
gin that you gifted me the botanist i
think you were giving those out one year
for
around the holidays was it botanist oh
it could have it could have been
botanist yeah
into one gym chin's the best yeah it's
so much more it's so much more
interesting than vodka right like it's
the the
botanicals in there and it's it's a
fantastic beverage
yeah i love i love uh i love
clean tequila i love
uh interesting gin and uh there's
something called sotol
s-o-t-o-l which is found in texas
which is also quite interesting it's
it's
for people who need a maybe a comparison
it might be somewhere between
tequila and mezcal oh
so a little bit more smoky then yeah
yeah there's not as hard but yeah
there's
exactly there's something called there's
a brand i think called desert door
which makes them really nice so tall
it's pretty hard to get
i also find that quite interesting but
if you drink enough of that
to get plastered you are going to feel
it for sure
the next day yeah oh bad like hangover
type
it's got that smoky it's got that smokey
element right same with mezcal oh
i mean i feel like a donkey's kicked me
in the forehead if i like
ashtray mouth the next morning like
you're just like oh yeah yeah yeah
like oh who had a campfire in my mouth
right that one
so you you mentioned dragons i think
it's it's important not to skip over
that one
fantastic tequila yeah it and also
fantastically expensive tequila they
actually
make a less expensive version now a
couple of them um
yeah okay which is great yeah casa
dragones the
the house of the dragon makes some
really nice stuff
and i was introduced to that uh pretty
funny story so i
i was first exposed to that am i making
you seasick with this camera
a little bit it keeps i think i'm like
out of focus it's like zooming in and
out i'm like if i drank that much like
you just keep going
right it's like the cinematographer like
imitation of being drunk
uh my god it's making me see sick just
looking at my own
my own image going on out of focus but
in any case uh casual dragon is i i was
first exposed to
when uh i spent time with a friend of
mine who's a former navy seal
and he and a bunch of guys were doing
weapons training
and shooting ranged practice with
you know all sorts like ar platform
handgun you know sidearm you name it
like all sorts of stuff
and their ritual was to then go back to
the house
disassemble all the guns and clean all
the guns while they're all sipping
casa dragon is oh my god but you can
disassemble like
like all the way down to bare metal or
like what are you talking about just
click just clean yeah it's general
cleaning
cleaning them but in some cases you know
disassembling
the the handguns and so on uh and
they're doing this very safely but we're
just like sitting around with a bunch of
like hyper masculine dudes who are like
real professionals i don't know what i'm
doing
but like cleaning guns drinking sipping
tequila right like no mixes
no cocktails just drinking sipping
tequila and
like uh it was amazing it was a great
experience
and a really great group of guys and i
had that and i had always had the
association with tequila
that it gave you a nasty hangover and i
drank so
much of this tequila woke up the next
day and i felt like a million bucks i
was like how is that even
possible so did you read about it do you
know what the deal is it's been
filtered 12 times the dragon is
well there you go yeah no it's like a
super ultra filtered it's like the
cleanest of the clean like it's
it that's why it's so expensive it's
fantastic yeah
so if you feel like getting a getting a
nice gift for somebody or for yourself
yeah that's one option all right two
more questions
does anything make you feel old or does
anything make you feel
young what makes me feel old
would be aching joints so elbow that
i've had elbow surgery on the wrist that
i've jacked up
i injured my lower back recently in a
stupid accident
uh joint pain makes me feel old same
dude
for sure for sure like muscular pain i
could deal with but like joint pain
makes me feel old makes me feel young
uh riding bicycles and riding my
girlfriend
those two oh jesus
dude this question is not going to make
it in
oh it'll make it it'll make it oh it was
great yeah yeah we'll see we'll see
those two those two things keep me young
[Laughter]
all right uh let's get a little
this is the uh this last question um
and it's more serious when i wanted to
end with this one uh because i do want
you take it seriously
uh you know we don't know how much time
we have left
and i am curious when you die
what do you ultimately want to be
remembered for
four-hour chef
[Laughter]
the stupid uh meme videos that i
texted kevin twice a week
let me think about that
you know i don't think any of us are
remembered for that long
uh i think that kind of over
focusing on legacy can
warp and contort a lot of thinking about
life and what you pursue right i think
it can
lead you to pursue things for prestige
uh
and i think uh you know prestige
approval guilt shame are all really bad
reasons for
doing things often times
and
you know as we were talking earlier
about
parenting and what kind of father i want
to be and i was talking about awareness
and engagement being these prerequisites
for other things
like you can try the tactical stuff but
if you lack that
base level that foundation
the rest of it doesn't really matter i
think that
in the last 10 years especially
five years especially last five months
in particular
i've realized that without hope the rest
of it just doesn't really matter
right so like you can give someone the
prescription the how to
you should do this you should do that
but without some level
of hope and and hope to me is slightly
has a slightly different
feeling to it than optimism i think
optimism can be a part of hope but that
hope is broader
uh without without some element of hope
a lot of that other
stuff just doesn't matter and get what
gets washed away so
i would like to be you know i used to
say
when people ask me like what would you
want to be remembered for like on your
gravestone i was like well as a
as a sort of creator of master students
who are better than himself right that
was an answer that i had
and i think now it would be as a
purveyor and provider of hope
like someone who's
providing hope to people who feel
hopeless
and not in a misleading not in a
pollyanna-ish
not in a naive way like i'm providing
hope because
i am a test subject right like i'm a
guinea pig
i'm someone who's suffered from severe
extended repeated bouts of depression
who is
uh on the front lines trying to
encourage the testing and research of
things like psilocybin and others that
show incredible promise for these
so-called intractable
untreatable psychiatric conditions
whether that's
depression or mdma assisted
psychotherapy for
complex treatment resistant ptsd right
post-traumatic stress disorder or
opioid use disorder anorexia these
things that have
really found no home from which
they can be treated effectively uh that
would be one example
you know one dimension to it so i would
say as a
as a seeker as a
fellow needer and hopefully
spreader of hope that's what i would
want
i i gotta tell you i i think that i a
lot of people would agree with this
statement and that
everything that you've done i mean when
i first met you was at your book launch
party for
the four-hour work week and then later
the four-hour body like that those have
all been about
hope they've been about how can i
improve
myself you know and how can i live and
do things
on my own time and by my own design
and you'd live a healthier lifestyle and
then now taking it to the more
philanthropic side of things
and working on mental health like this
is the easy thing for you to
accomplish because like you've already
done it like your career has been all
about hope so
i think you inspire a lot of people um
and for that reason so this is this is
that's great
it's uh thanks man no it's
something to look up to like i know you
and i talk about this and we have a
slightly different take on
on uh philanthropy and that you know
i've done
bits and pieces of it um my take and it
could be the wrong one
but i'm in like the prime of my earning
career and i think that
i want to like get a little bit more
resources so that i can do
bigger impact things long term but like
you're definitely an inspiration for me
on that front
um and certainly something that i want
to eventually
imitate and figure out how to do is have
a bigger impact in that way so
thank you for all that you've done on
that and dude it's been awesome that
you'd even share the space
with me for episode 500 so thank you for
that as well yeah
thanks kev kev yeah it's uh
you know i i want to give my uh give
some some additional thanks to my
girlfriend
so that i don't have my last mention of
her and the same answer at the bicycle
which uh which is you know i when i was
considering
what to do about
sharing my experiences with abuse as a
kid
i told her about the plans for the book
the possible book which would be
years off in the future and
the possibility of then
doing a podcast maybe as a stopgap
measure
or even a replacement for doing the book
because it would be sooner
and you know she just made the point
that if you looked at the discrepancy
between those two
let's say a podcast coming out in a few
months and a book coming out
four or five years later that
there there would be and there are
many people who would die by natural
causes
take their own lives via suicide or
otherwise
not ever have access to the book
who would benefit from the podcast and i
think that there's
there's compounding of wealth and
resources
and you can make many compelling
arguments for if and when to
jump into the fray to try to address
problems based on
compound interest and so on i would just
offer to people who are
thinking about this for themselves that
there's certain problems that compound
also
and there are certain problems certain
subsets of populations and so on who
are more easily reached
more easily addressed more easily helped
now than they will be in a year or two
years because the problems compound at a
faster rate than your capital
uh so you know that that's that's
that's one perspective that i would
offer not to say that everybody should
immediately jump into the fray and
use as much as they can afford to affect
change in the world i don't think that's
true for everyone i think that's
absolutely not the case for everyone but
for me
at least with some of these mental
health conditions and having the
ability to set precedent right to create
the first center in the world dedicated
to psychedelic research to create the
first center
in the u.s dedicated to psychedelic
research and consciousness research
offered me a rare window and opportunity
to tip the first domino in a way
that i knew would then trigger and
unlock all sorts of other developments
right so i was able to put in say a
million dollars for the expectation that
it would generate
10 or 100 million dollars in impact
uh so so i do think that
uh you got to pick your time you got to
pick your target
you really want to be surgical with this
stuff and very thoughtful
and there are sometimes just like with
startups
right there are some times when you're
like oh damn there's that
one window right that door opens a crack
and that's your shot like you have a
real opportunity to make an impact and
for me i just felt that way
in the last few years yeah but i'm
excited to
i'm excited to see what you do too man
yeah it makes it makes a lot of sense if
you think about it because there was
um this little tipping point that
happened where all of a sudden there was
a window to
create some research around psychedelic
use you know that
because if the government had totally
locked this thing down like let's say we
were in some country that was just
clamped down on both the federal and
state level
it would be probably like pissing away
money at that point right because they
wouldn't you wouldn't even be able to
fund research but
you had you found a window the momentum
was going in the right direction
and now you know we're seeing benefits
from that in terms of it being legalized
like in oregon and other places where
this could be real therapies going in
into people in the next year or so you
know which is really cool
yeah yeah yeah it's moved a lot faster
than i
ever could have hoped and there's there
are going to be
challenges they're going to be setbacks
they're going to be messes they're going
to be
uh players
in the arena with less than pure motives
which is to be expected and
um that's all that's all part of the
game so
yeah well the last thing i want to say
is
um and i'd be curious to know how you
were able to do this in yourself is that
one of the things that i i want to push
more forward especially given that i
have a couple daughters and i think that
more men should be vulnerable
people like able to talk about like
you've talked about
um suicide and depression and child
abuse and like all these
really tough sensitive topics and you
know i've certainly talked about
couples therapy and the abuse my father
gave my mom and things like that like
we need to encourage more of that and i
just want to say thanks to you
you've helped me be more open with
myself and my audience about those
things and i think
it's that like starting that
conversation oh if tim can talk about it
i can too
it's such an important thing that we all
need to do oh thanks kevin
thanks man it's the truth though dude
like it really is
like it helps me when i you talk about
this stuff i can talk about it like and
i know that's the same with so many
other people so so anyway thanks brother
cheers to you brother uh congratulations
on 500 wishing you to 500 more or
a thousand more when do you hang it up
by the way how many do you think you got
left in you
i have no plans to hang it up at this
point you know this this gives me
this is uh this is joyful for me it's
fun for me
and if it stops being fun
uh it's it's either time to hang it up
or more likely
it's time for me to change something and
i've just succumbed
to some temptation that i need to fix
right like for this episode
let's take this episode as an example
number 500 right i could have done like
lessons learned over 500 episodes and
done like a monologue
right instead you get viagra questions
[Laughter]
which is more fun it's more fun for me
it's more fun it gives me more energy it
gives me more pleasure like this is a
good time
and like you said you don't know how
much time you have left
nobody does and so it's like if
if you're not having fun uh at least in
my life
like chances are it's my fault
[ __ ] fix it you know and
if the choices you're making your
default choices or the way things are
set up
aren't working change it experiment try
something else so for me
the way that you know i used to do six
episodes a month with the podcast i cut
back to four
on average and i used to handle say
sponsorships and this that the other
thing a certain way and then i changed
it
because it was starting to feel like an
obligation and i was starting to
uh procrastinate and not look forward to
it
uh so you know this is i think a game of
iteration and what
what might give me joy today might not
give me joy tomorrow and
things change they evolve over time but
i love doing the podcast so yeah
wouldn't surprise me if i do another 500
another thousand
and then take a look and reassess yeah i
think that really it doesn't really
matter where you are in life because i
remember
you know when i was not like being in vc
and doing these things
i left olive garden which had good tips
and unlimited bread sticks to work at
computer city
for less pay but you know what i was a
hell of a lot happier when i was working
in computer city
than i was at olive garden so it's like
you just gotta do it you gotta change it
up if it's not working
switch it up you gotta switch it up man
and uh it's so good to see you yeah i
miss you brother
i miss you two in person sometime soon
what's up tv let's get these shots
and make exactly right
and uh to everybody listening
uh i love you guys you know i really
so deeply appreciate everybody listening
it gives me the opportunity to play
gives me the opportunity to push
to challenge myself also to try to do
things i don't think i can do
with respect to this podcast to wrangle
people i think can't be wrangled and
also
just as important to shoot the [ __ ] and
talk about viagra
people like kevin yeah
so so i really really appreciate
everyone who tunes into this podcast and
i know this has been a loosey-goosey
banter-filled episode but this is what i
wanted to do
and ultimately the only way i'll keep
doing this
is if i have some fun along the way
thanks for having me tim that was
awesome yeah brother
i'll see you soon
you